So I think that we can get started.
Good morning, everyone. I'm Barbara Pistilli, medical oncologist
at Gustave Roussy, France, and I'm very pleased
to
welcome all of you to this mini symposium late-breaking
research
that I'm going to co-chair with Dr Colleen Weeks
from Massachusetts General Hospital.
Just a couple of words. We have seven late-breaking abstract,
and we have 10 minutes for each presentation, and at the end of each
presentation, five minutes for the questions.
I try just to summarize a little bit what are the key points, the key
topics that are going to be covered by the seven abstract.
The first abstract on the wide genomic characterization of pre-cancer
lesions, discerning between
biologically aggressive from indolent lesions.
And then we have three abstract on therapeutically actionable
vulnerabilities across BRCA1 deficient
tumors, but also in dormant breast cancer cell and in
prostate cancer. And finally, three abstract that are
looking at new therapeutic approach across
BRAF mutant glioma, but also in pancreatic
intraepithelial neoplasia, and also in metastatic
pancreatic cancer.
So without any further ado, I would like to introduce the
first speaker.
Let me see in the program.
So the first speaker is Dr Steele,
and the title is "The Genomic Landscape of Likely Human
Pre-cancers."
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity to talk today.
It's very fitting that the first
talk of this session is on pre-cancers, moving into cancers later.
And as such, I will be discussing the genomic landscape of likely human
pre-cancers. I have no financial relationships to
disclose
. So first things first, what exactly is pre-cancer?
Well, it represents an intermediate stage between normal tissues
and invasive cancer tissue. It can be recognized
as morphologically distinct from normal tissue, either macroscopically,
as seen on the right-hand side for a cervical pre-cancer,
or histologically, seen in the bottom right for a skin
pre-cancer. Importantly, pre-cancers have a propensity to
progress to cancer,
and it's important to
identify them early, as there are some options to intervene,
such as polypectomy as a surgical intervention or
mammography or a CT scan for surveillance
for less serious pre-cancers.
I've used the term pre-cancer pretty definitively, but actually, it's
become clear over the last decades that pre-cancer
is a little bit more nebulous than you might believe.
So screening programs over the last decade have found that pre-cancers are
much more prevalent than they were previously thought to be,
ranging from 10% to 50% of the
population, depending on the tissue that we're looking at.
However, the vast majority of pre-cancers will never progress to cancer,
and the progression rate can vary from, as you see, less than 1% for
pancreatic cysts all the way up to 25% for breast
DCIS.
Importantly, overdiagnosis is not risk-free.
If you intervene, there are possibilities for surgical
complications such as sepsis, and
diagnosing a patient with a pre-cancer comes with some psychological stress as
well, which can lead to adverse outcomes such as,
in extreme cases, suicide.
So the real question is, can we better stratify the 1% to 25% of
pre-cancers that will progress from the 75% to
99% that will never progress? And maybe we should think of them as something
distinct from pre-cancer.
To do this, we've put together a comprehensive data set of pre-cancers.
Initially, we had just over 1,700 samples, but
after rigorous quality control, this dropped down to just under
1,500 pre-cancer samples from 33 different
pre-cancer types spanning 24 different tissues in the human body.
These were subject to a mixture of whole genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing, and run through a standardized NGS
pipeline for mutation calling.
We focused on somatic data types for this study, identifying
mutations, some derived metrics such as
ploidy, percent genome aberrant, and tumor mutational burden.
We also did some driver calling, and we looked at mutational
signatures such as SBS signatures and copy number signatures.
The first thing that we can look at from this data is the genome-wide
heterogeneity that we see in pre-cancer, and it's really
quite extreme when you look at it. So this top panel here is
the coding SBS and Indel burden across the coding
genome. And this ranges from less than 10 coding
mutations in the coding genome, as you can see on the left-hand side for
testis pre-cancers, all the way up to over 3,000 coding
mutations, which we see in a few colon adenomas and
some skin pre-cancers. So this represents really a large level of
inter-tissue heterogeneity at a mutational burden
level.We also see heterogeneity at an intra
precancer level. And I'm just showing here for colon adenomas,
where we have the bulk of the tumors showing
about 1.5-ish coding SBS and
indel per megabase.
But we do see some hypermutators, and we have verified that these have
mutations in MLH1 or MSH2. I remind you, these
are precancers and not cancers, and we see the hypermutator phenotype
at this early stage of tumorigenesis.
We also see intra-tissue heterogeneity.
So both of these are colon precancers, and we can see that they
vary in their average mutational burden across
these different precancer types within the same tissue.
We also see similar levels of heterogeneity in the copy number profiles
as opposed to SBS and indel profiles I showed you previously.
So here in the middle panel, we have the percent of genome aberrant to copy number
alterations. And at the bottom, we have the percentage of samples that are whole
genome doubled. And again, these range from precancers that have
essentially nothing going on in terms of copy number, all the way up
to precancers that have, on average, 70% of the
genome altered by some kind of copy number alteration, and as
many as 68% of samples being whole genome doubled.
So again, a large level of heterogeneity.
Next, we wanted to look into driver gene alterations.
So, I can't go into all the detail, but this panel shows a
number of bona fide cancer driver genes, and
we see driver alterations in these genes at this early level of
tumorigenesis as well. So the highlighted section here is showing
APC alterations in colorectal
precancers. We see them at this early stage, and we also
see double hit mutations in, for instance, TP53
and CDKN2A at this early stage of tumorigenesis.
Importantly, 43% of the samples in our study showed no
detectable driver gene alterations.
Compare this to 11% in TCGA across cancers.
So this really indicates that we need to look beyond driver gene alterations to
understand what is going on in these lesions.
To do this, I wanted to take a holistic approach across our data
set. So I combined aneuploidy data, driver
alterations, SBS signatures, copy number signatures, and
our previously shown genome-wide metrics of genomic
instability across our data set and across
precancers. And I put these into a random forest model to try and
predict whether a sample is precancer or cancer.
Each of these vertical bars indicates an individual patient.
And a value of 1.0 indicates that that sample was
predicted to be 100% precancer-like, and a value of
0.0 indicates the sample was predicted to be 100% cancer-like
at a genomic level.
So again, we see large heterogeneity here, and I'll just focus on
one tissue to give you a through line.
So if we look at lung precancers, there is a
hypothesized progression from hyperplasia to adenocarcinoma in
situ. And if we look at these two precancer types within
this result, we see that the cancer-like
score or one minus the precancer-like score increases
as you move from hyperplasia to adenocarcinoma in situ, perhaps
suggesting that genomic complexity is increasing as you
progress through the different stages of precancer.
We also have data from adenocarcinoma in situ.
These are squamous cell lung precancers, and these dichotomize
into two individual groups, one showing a high
precancer-like genomic phenotype and one showing a high cancer-like
phenotype, indicating that maybe these dichotomize into low-risk
carcinoma in situ and high-risk carcinoma in situ.
Unfortunately for this precancer type, we don't have the clinical
data to really answer whether this is what we're seeing.
However, for one of our data sets, we do have such
information. For our Barrett's esophagus data, we have cancer outcome data
for these patients, and we can see that this same score correlates
with cancer outcomes. So as you move from the left to the right, we move from
no cancer outcome patients to cancer outcome patients, where the
sample was taken asynchronously to the cancer.
So the sample was taken previous to cancer.
And on the right-hand side, the sample was taken synchronously with the cancer.
And we can see that the cancer-like score increases as we move through those
different stages, suggesting that this score has some
utility in finding
less benign precancers.
We can then ask what features predict malignant potential using this model.
And I've just focused on the top 40 features here, and the top
three features were the same features I showed you in the first results
slide. Tumor mutational burden,
ploidy, and the proportion of genome aberrant by copy number alterations
were the three most important features for determining malignant potential.
We also see copy number alterations across a large number of our
top 40 features. These seem to be key in determining
whether something has malignant potential or not.
We also see a couple of driver gene alterations, CDKN2A and TP53.
Again, the two most commonly altered genes in cancer and in
precancer,
and also a couple of signatures of hypermutation.
So in summary, we've shown a proof of concept that genomic profiling can
discern precancers from cancers and that genomic variability
acts as the soil within which malignancy develops.
We would love to
extend this to really ask the question that we want, which is: can we
separate indolent precancers from high-risk
precancers? But we need better clinical data to be able to answer that
specific question.
There are some data modalities that were not included in this study that might be
important in explaining what is causing some of these lesions, and
those might include epigenetic factors, transcriptomic factors, the immune
environment, germline features, and structural
variants.I would just like to thank everybody in the lab and all the
collaborators who've worked on this. In particular, Phoebe He.
She did a huge amount of work on this study, so thanks to her.
And if you have any questions, I'd be happy to answer them now.
I think everybody can hear me? Ah, okay.
Any question?
Can I... Okay.
Can I start with the question?
Sure.
So the data that you have shown are very interesting, but
I have the impression that we have this continuum of data for the
patients that finally develop a cancer, but we are missing data
for the patients or non-patients in reality
for
whom this indolent disease remain like this.
Yes.
How do you think we can fill in this gap?
There are some ideas, some effort that are
currently ongoing.
I'm not aware of any efforts that are currently ongoing, but I think it needs to
be in discussion with clinicians.
At the moment, part of the problem is that some pre-cancers will regress,
so they kind of disappear.
And then once they've regressed, patients stop going to the doctor for them.
They're not interested in them anymore, which makes sense.
But I think maybe it would be beneficial if clinicians
had these in the back of their mind and could follow up these patients if
possible. It's really a data collection problem.
Hi. Great talk.
Thank you.
I'm wondering, do you guys have any pre-cancer lesions from any
patients with germline predisposition syndromes?
In those cases,
do you see those corresponding signatures?
Or I guess, in other words, are these genes haploinsufficient?
Mm-hmm. That's a good question. We wanted to exclude germline
predispositions in this study. But it is something that is worth looking
into.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you.
The second speaker is Dr. Raphael.
Homologous recombination deficiency synthesise breast
cancer to therapeutic targeting of
ectonucleotidase
ENPP1.
All right. Thank you for the invitation to speak.
I do have one disclosure related to a pending patent on antibody I'll talk about at
the end of the few minute talk.
So my lab's really interested in understanding, basically in breast cancer,
why these respond very poorly to immune checkpoint blockade.
So what are the immunosuppressive factors driving these poor responses?
Particularly in the triple negative breast cancer subset, where we know a large
majority of these are essentially immune positive.
They have a nice and rich score for immune infiltration,
which presumably should mark a highly responsive population.
And we were very interested when this paper came out from UCSF, which noted that
this immune infiltration is very related to this DNA repair defect
signature, they noted in this fairly large cohort of patients from the
I-SPY 2 trial.
And so why might this be the case? And it's been really nicely shown by multiple
groups that
when you have defects in DNA repair, and these are mostly related to BRCA1
deficiencies, you wind up having the accumulation of damaged
DNA in the cytosol of tumor cells. This then leads
to activation of the cGAS and STING pathway, with the
intermediate production of this dinucleotides called cGAMP, which we'll touch on a
little bit later. That then turns on a classic type I interferon response,
and then essentially has that classic immune activation.
Notably, several groups, particularly the Rolle and the Li lab from Stanford,
showed that not only does this pathway turn activate in tumor cells,
but the release of this cGAMP intermediate can actually happen into extracellular
space, and they can activate the host immune response as well.
So essentially when you have this DNA repair defect, you can turn on both
tumor and host immune activation.
So then this should be a really good thing.
We should see really high immune infiltration, and so why don't these patients
respond?
Well, one thing was identified both by the Li lab originally, as well as some extra
work by the Backhome lab, where they showed that there's this
ectonucleotidase called ENPP1 on the surface.
This is in the same family as the CD39 and CD73 family.
And what this does is actually cleave this dinucleotide into its
requisite components, AMP and GMP,
as well as degrade extracellular ATP.
And this can then produce, through the CD73 pathway, suppressive
adenosine and essentially shut down.
So as Tom Gaisky say, you're essentially turning off the gas as well as applying
the brakes at the same time.
But despite this, if you knock out this gene from tumor cells, at least the
primary tumor, it doesn't care. There is less metastasis, and they do become
slightly more susceptible to immune checkpoint blockade, but primary tumors grow as
if nothing had happened. And so we're really curious.
Well, maybe the problem is not that this is not an interesting molecule.
Maybe the problem is we're just asking the wrong question in the wrong model
system.
And so my student in the lab went to the human
TCA datasets and asked, "Where is ENPP1 important?" And so
if you look at BRCA1 type disease, you see expression of ENPP1, it doesn't matter
in terms of outcome. And in this very small group of patients,
you see with those who have BRCA mutations, you see a large difference in the
survival of these patients. Now, this is probably heavily biased by subtype and a
really low
number of patients, and so she also scanned another datasetThat came
out here in 2019. And this is all TNBC patients.
And again, you see patients who have functional BRCA1 genes, both in
terms of lack of mutations as well as a high expression,
have essentially no survival advantage or disadvantage with high expression,
whereas those with a non-functional mutation do see the survival difference.
So with that, we essentially went to our mouse models.
We made a BRCA deficient mouse model to interrogate this in
syngeneic model systems, and we made two cell lines with BRCA deficiency.
Both of these had very high prevalence of the cytosolic double-strand DNA that we
expected, shown here in green. Notably, they also very highly
expressed the essentially induced expression of this ENPP1
nucleotide.
And so we want to interrogate what role this had.
So when we knocked it out of other tumor models, shown here is the PYMT
E0771, as well as something else we made called the KP1 TNBC
cell line, essentially no difference.
Repeating what had been published in the literature.
But now when we put it into BRCA deficient lines, now we saw very substantial
differences in tumor growth in the absence of any kind of therapeutic intervention.
If we had a slightly slower growing model, it was to the point that not only did we
have slower tumors growing, but we actually had rejection in about half of the mice
that had implanted with this tumor model.
And so what was going on here? Maybe not surprising for having tumor rejection, we
had higher infiltration of CD8 T cells.
These CD8 T cells were more interferon gamma and expressing,
as well as slightly higher infiltration of other things like CD4s and NK cells.
Notably, if we depleted CD8 T cells, the phenotype completely disappeared, whereas
if we depleted CD8s and NK cells, the phenotype was fairly modest.
So we did single cell to understand what was happening to all these immune cells
here in the deficient tumors. What we saw most prominently was large
changes in macrophage gene expression profiles,
and in particularly expression of genes related to class one and class two
expression. We confirmed these by flow cytometry, releasing a higher
expression of antigen presentation by these macrophages present within the
tumors deficient in ENPP1.
We then went to ask, does these macrophages actually responding to this
extracellular cGAMP production?
So we took advantage of these STING flox mice, and if we look at
control mice, the tumors grow slower when they lack ENPP1.
If we put them in mice which have a LysM-Cre where they lose expression of this
STING gene in macrophages, these no longer have a difference in growth.
And as a control, we also put these in mice that lack STING expression in dendritic
cells, because classically it's thought that STING activation in dendritic cells is
really driving anti-tumor immunity.
But we found this was irrelevant, at least in this one model system.
This change in tumor volume was marked by similar matches in essentially a loss of
the CD8 T cell infiltration, shown here in the middle, loss of CD4, CD8s,
no longer an increase in interferon gamma expression, and no longer a change
in the phenotype of macrophages that we had been seeing.
We also confirmed that this was functionally relevant, so not just changes in the
genome or the protein level. We actually took macrophages out from tumors, and
shown here is a classic T cell suppression assay.
So shown here, if you activate T cells, they proliferate very nicely.
If you incubate them with macrophages from tumors, essentially shuts down the
proliferation. But if you take them from macrophages from tumors that
do not express ENPP1, they now proliferate as happily as if they'd not been seeing
macrophages at all, at least at this lower concentration of
macrophages. And notably, when we did the same thing with STING flox mice, this
phenotype went away. So STING activation in macrophages was actually required for
this version of the immunosuppressive phenotype.
Now,
we'd assumed that production of
cGAS and STING and cGAMP would be from tumor cells, but we wanted to confirm that
was the case. And so what we did was we knocked out the cGAS gene from tumor cells,
assuming that that would then prevent any kind of signature that we were seeing.
And indeed, when we knocked out cGAS, the tumors grew normally.
So if there's no cGAMP in the tumors, there's no activation of the immune response.
Now, as a control, we also knocked out STING from tumor cells, thinking that this
would have no real phenotype, because presumably the degradation of the
extracellular molecule would activate the host and not the tumor.
But in fact, we found that it was identical.
So the host and the tumor response to STING was equally critical for
this role of this one extracellular nucleotide, suggesting that the
release of this molecule by tumor cells is actually, in an autocrine or
paracrine fashion, activating neighboring tumor cells.
To ask what was happening here, we did bulk RNA-seq, and we found
that, essentially in the absence of ENPP1, and the phenotype was reversed by
the lack of tumor STING, we had higher expression of all the classic
immune markers, but particularly a higher expression of MHC class I on the tumor
cells. And then inversely, we saw a very low expression and low infiltration
of neutrophils, which a point I won't touch on at all later on
today. We confirmed the increased expression of MHC-I
on the tumor cells, as shown here by flow cytometry.
This also led to increased expression of a model tumor antigen, which we put
inside the tumor cells, in this case Siglec-F.
And then these tumor cells were now more susceptible to direct CD8 mediated killing
in an antigen-specific manner. And finally, we actually tried to put these back
into mice to really characterize what these tumors were looking at, if we
had no higher antigen expression, we could track the immune response.
But what we found was when they were expressing OVA, they just couldn't grow.
So if we just a little bit increased the antigenicity of these tumors in the
absence of EP1, they were completely unable to grow in these mice any longer.
So moving beyond just a single
agent or a direct single knockout, we
interrogated the response of these tumors to standard of care of
essentially, well, in this case,
niraparib, which is not standard of care for breast cancer, but it was a really
effective
PARP inhibitor in our hands. And then we also interrogated
response to anti-PD-1. Notably, as in clinical trials, if you combine
niraparib and anti-PD-1 in patients, there's no effect.
So the combination, although it was a good idea, we don't see any effect in the
patients over multiple clinical trials.
But notably, when we did the same thing in the ENPP1 knockouts, each alone had a
similar effect, but when we combined them, we now started seeing really prolonged
tumor control, and the occasional rejection as well, which then led to
enhanced survival only in this group.
So we only saw combination efficacy in this one group.So
knowing that if we knock it out, it's important.
We also want to ask, can we target this therapeutically?
So a chemist at Moffitt, as well as a
protein engineer at Moffitt got together and developed
or remade the inhibitors that had been published by the Lee and Wells lab at
Stanford and UCSF respectively. And both of these work fairly well at actually
inhibiting tumor growth in our model system, achieving roughly half the tumor
control we see when we knock out the gene entirely.
But this wasn't quite where we wanted, so we tried to make our own antibody as
well. We found this antibody that was made by the Lucca lab.
It's actually an antibody and then put into either a human or mouse
construct. We found this was quite efficient at binding. It was very stable.
And then it worked on both human and mouse to bind very well to the different cell
lines, as well as to inhibit the degradation of CCAMP.
And importantly, when we put this back in the mouse, we found that this B7 antibody
that targets very effectively human and mouse CMPP1, was equal to the
knocking out the gene entirely in tumors at controlling tumor volume.
And then both as a single agent and in combination with niraparib and anti-PD1,
we had really prolonged tumor control in these mice.
So with that, I think I've run out of time, so I'll skip the summary slide.
But what I really wanted to do is thank the really talented work from my lab,
particularly Jiayi Li, who led this project from the start,
as well as help from the Lucca lab and Charlotte.
I mean, his lab,
various other collaborators at Moffitt, including the Lopucki lab, and then the
funding shown here. With that, I'll take any questions. Thank you.
Any
question?
It was all clear, so that's good.
Can I ask, how do you imagine a clinical trial
with the PARP inhibitor and an antibody?
I would hope that it may work.
Perhaps in refractory patients, we could try the antibody as a single
agent. Ideally, probably in combination, though.
When it's most effective would be obviously the earlier we go, the more effective
it might be. But if we can repeat those early trials with the inhibitor,
and with standard of care, that would be ideal.
Thank you.
Dr. Ahat will join us.
And his talk is titled Mechanisms of Tumor Dormancy Through Immune Niche
Formation and Its Impact on Immune Therapeutic Relapse.
Yeah.
Good evening, everyone. Thank you to the chair and ACR for the opportunity
to present our work, which is about how some cancer
cells survive the immune pressure by entering the tumor dormancy.
And we just see the previous, our colleague showed the wonderful data in the breast
cancer that anti-tumor immunity is so important, but not always. There is a caveat.
That's what I'm going to talk about.
So I don't have any financial things to disclose.
This is my outline, where I will briefly set up the background,
introduction of tumor dormancy, and our lab research.
And I'll focus mainly on three questions.
First, how tumor cells acquire the dormancy phenotype in our mouse
model. The second,
how they avoid immune elimination once dormant by
acquiring distinct immune niche.
And the third, I'll end with how their inhibitory access
may provide a way to target relapse.
So
disseminated tumor cells from the primary tumor, they hide in
non-dividing, a very slow-growing state called dormant state,
which can give rise to the metastatic relapse months, years, even
decades later.
There are two main models established in the field.
First is cellular dormancy, where cancer
tumor cells
enter reversible quiescent state by reducing the growth pathways and
increase p38. There's another model where there is tumor mass dormancy,
where proliferation versus
killing, there is a balance. So overall size doesn't change.
My work mostly support the primary first model, which is cellular
dormancy.
The practical challenge in the field is that we don't have very mechanistic
immune competent mouse model for the tumor dormancy.
As I said, our lab mainly working on the breast cancer,
especially triple-negative breast cancer metastasis.
And previously, we showed that TGBH receptor 2 increase in the myeloid
cells in the tumor tissues, and that deleting in myeloid cells
specifically reduces the metastasis a lot.
But I was very interested to know,
in these small remaining disseminated lesions, what
happens.
So we used inducible S2GP system in the cancer
cells. After the tail vein injection into the wild type knockout mouse,
we added the doxycycline shortly before imaging so that
these rare single disseminated lesions can
visible in the lung surface so that you can visualize it
without having any immune rejection.
What we saw was striking. If you see in the wild-type mouse, the
tumor lesions,
they become very large. The metastasis are large.
In the knockout lesion, mostly these lesions remain as
one to eight cell lesion over the time.
The total lesion number was not dramatically changed early on,
which is inconsistent with the cellular dormancy rather than failure of tumor
seeding.
Moreover, we use CVC, a membrane dye, which dilute
after the cell division, as you can see here.
So that GFP tumor cells retaining the
CVC therefore considered as low dividing or non-dividing cells.
In the knockout setting, these cells we showedThat they have
more P38 and the P27, which is a stimulus questions marker.
And this also gave us a way to sort these dormant versus proliferative tumor
cells to perform the RNAseq, to get the more mechanistic insight.
So
as I said, we have the threshold for the one to X cell lesions
as dormant. We say dormant lesions.
More than eight cells lesion in the tissue, we say those
are proliferative.
Okay. Once we knew the dormant lesions, next, we
were interested to know what are the microenvironment.
So we in collaboration with Dr. Ranjan at NIH, we used
their published study IBEX for the multiplex imaging to
define the local immune neighborhood in each tumor
lesions across the tissue. What revealed it was two distinct
immune niche.
So the proliferative lesion, as you can see, they are
more in the wild type mouse. They were enriched with the alveolar
macrophages and T cells. On the other hand, the dormant
lesions, they were more biased to the knockout mouse.
They were enriched with the monocyte,
neutrophils, dendritic cells, and NK
cells.
One interesting observation was that the relative absence of the
T cell in dormant lesions, which in partly consistent with one of the
previous published from the Cyrus group, they showed that there is a relative
absence of the T cell in the next to the dormant lesions.
But it is different from the recently published from the Julius group.
They showed the relevance of the alveolar macrophage in the
dormancy, which partly because of our model is different or maybe
the timing of the snapshot.
Okay, but I was very particularly interested because these lesions, they
have the NK cell, which are very potent antitumor tumor killing
cells. Then how tumor cell was surviving in this niche.
So, as we said, we had the RNAseq data.
We did the pathway analysis from the sorted dormant versus proliferative tumor
cells, differential gene expression.
And we have the enriched immune regulatory pathways, where the
CD200 stood out as a top candidate.
CD200 is a known inhibitory ligand.
Its receptor mostly present on the immune cells,
and physiologically, these axes are very important to keep
the inflammation controlled.
We validated that CD200 were high in the dormant tumor cell in the knockout mouse.
The next one, to see what immune cells having this receptor.
So we get it on the CD200 are hypo cells in the immune cells, and we found
in the knockout mouse we have more NK cells.
And macrophage were down, but overall, consistent with the previous study,
the macrophages were more
major cell type in this fraction as
reported in the field. Okay. Then as a special
imaging also, we found in these dormant lesions, they have more of this
CD200r positive NK cells.
This suggesting that these dormant tumor cells, they
are surviving in this niche, not because they
lacks the immune cells, because somehow they
use the inhibitory pathway to limit this NK cell mediated killing.
To test directly this hypothesis, we co-culture this CD200
overexpression tumor cells with NK cell macrophage, and we found the CD200
overexpression cells,
they were less sensitive to the NK cell killing.
We also injected in the mouse with CD200 knockdown cells, and you
see here that very specifically the dormant lesion were marked,
specifically reduced, whereas there were less effect on the proliferative
lesions.
In contrary, when we injected the CD200 overexpressed even in the wild type mice,
we see more burden of disseminated tumor lesions.
And this is something like it
led us to ask the therapeutic question,
to using the CD200 overexpression
system as a preclinical model, where group of the mouse, they were treated with the
cisplatin and immune checkpoint
blockage, where it was an anti-PD-1.
It is specifically mostly remove the
actively growing lesions, leaving behind these single dormant
lesions. Residual cells, I would say.
When you added the anti-CD200 treatment in the group of
mouse, so the residual tumor cells, they are
specifically eradicated.
Then next, we ask more clinical relevant question.
What about this regimen in this group?
If you pause or withdraw, whether this residual tumor cell itself, they
will grow back, and if you keep the pressure of the
anti-CD200,
whether it can be prevented. That's what we did in our relapse model.
So the group of mouse which this regimen
was paused--
Sorry, this regimen was paused, that there was
regrowth
of these tumor lesions, the proliferative tumor lesions come back, whether it was
completely prevented when you had the anti-CD200 blockage.
In summary, most of data I didn't show, it is preprint.
You can just see. What I
showed here that in the Tgp-myeloid knockout mouse, you have
very high strong antitumor immunity, especially IFN-gamma rich
environment. It induces
KLF4 through interferon gamma receptor.
KLF4 itself induces CD200, which is very important
for this dormant tumor cell to survive in this niche by inhibiting the NK cells.
So these are my labs, my mentor, Dr.
Li Yang, and my staff scientist, Jie, is here, and all of the
other staff, my collaborator who helped me directly or indirectly in this project.
And I'm happy to take your questions.
Any questions for Dr. Ahad?
That showed that the GFP and the bio C background was very immunodominant.
And that drove a lot of their T-cell selection pressures.
So have you tried the role of CD200 in
E0771 or some other metastatic model where you don't have the mate unit peptides?
So, first thing,
to tackle that immune
rejection problem,
as I said, we use inducible GFP, not consistent GFP-expressing cells.
So what we did, we inject the normal cells, they have the inducible GFP.
When you want to sacrifice the mice, two days before, you just inject the
doxycycline. So it avoids that problem of immune rejection.
That's what we use that approach from the Cyrus paper.
Right.
Okay. But as different models, we use multiple model,
especially mostly aggressive model, triple-negative
model, hard to model. So what the idea was, this is not model
specific, not cell intrinsic based.
Actually, this is a microenvironment which created under the TGB
beta R2 knockout, so high inflammatory, is anti-tumor immunity, but
somehow some cancer cells, they escape by having this mechanism.
That's the whole idea.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So,
the next abstract is,
sorry,
Ligandable PNT domain establishes ERG as a directable,
targetable oncogenic driver in prostate cancer. Dr. Wang.
Thanks.
Thank you.
First, thank you for the opportunity to present.
I guess we are all occupied by exciting data in last couple of
days.
Today, I try to make it simple, easy to
share my unpublished data on targeting ERG
transcription factor in prostate, mainly focus on our
ligandable domain, which we believe are going to open a
new therapeutic avenue.
I don't have
relations to disclose. So as we know, I think,
the audience in this room are pretty familiar with prostate cancer, so I
don't
think it's necessary to introduce the background.
But one thing is I want to highlight is the majority of prostate
harbor the recurrent gene fusion involve the ETS
family,
which identified in our lab led by Scott
Tomlin. So the majority of this
rearrangement happen to be TMPRSS2 and ERG
gene fusion.
It's overexpressing in 50% of prostate cancer patients
with European ancestry. The rest of this
ETS family, including FLI1, ETV5, ETV4, and so on and so
forth, account about 10%.
Mechanistically,
driven by AR binding to the promoter of
TMPRSS2, and this leads to the pathogenic
overexpression of the
chimeric transcript. So which
encode nearly full length of ERG protein.
And so this ERG protein function, this ERG protein bind to the
AR and then reprogram the AR network.
This rewiring AR program also enhance
proliferation and migration of prostate cancer patients.
So very importantly, this observation occur very
early and also is maintained throughout this
tumor progression. So which make this
rearrangement observation as a very stable and therapeutically related
target.
So
to further understand the dependence or
establish the biologic rationale to target the
ERG
protein. So we evaluate the
importance of ERG in panel of cell
lines using that map. From this dependency, we can
see the VCaP cells, which is the only one
prostate cancer cell line harbor the T2ERG gene fusion
is very dependent on the ERG knockout and
together with other subsites of
hemomalignancy. And
therefore, in this study, we
use VCaP and other
N6 IH as model to characterize this ERG
dependency.
So in our lab, we create or establish a
generate inducible knockdown model by
using the shRA. So here, this is
our IHC data to show the ERG knockdown
you can see here. The link cap is
ERG negative cell line. We can see there's no
stain. And upon the doxycycline treatment, using 1
microgram per mil of doxycycline, we can
see almost completely knocked down the ERG protein.
And it's also in the immunoc, we can see this by western
blot, can see the ERG band almost completely depleted, and
induce the clear PARP. So
indicating this apoptosis, induced
apoptosis by the knockdown of ERG.
And we also
look at or assess the
clonogenic potential by ERG. So we can see here,
so upon doxycycline treatment, the ERG knockdown almost completely
inhibit or block the
tube colony formation, which is shown here.
And this is a graph demonstrate or quantify the
differences.And so
finally, we move to the in vivo to try to see the
dependency or the requirement of ERG in the in vivo model.
Here we can see the ERG IF upon the...
This PD5 study at D5, we collect the tissue.
We can see the ERG protein completely
knocked down.
And so this is the western blot, further show the knockdown the ERG
protein and induce apoptosis, as you can see here.
So in line with this clear path, we can see here
the apoptosis, which is detected by TUNEL, you can see huge
light up with the TUNEL signal, and its quantification of
this ah H score.
To extend the treatment in vivo
model, we can easily see the ERG knockdown can
completely suppress tumor growth even up to 70 days.
Together, this data clearly demonstrate the ERG is
a stable and very reliable therapeutic
target we can focus. But
ERG as a transcription factor, we all know that it's historically
considered undruggable. There's a few reasons.
Here,
as we know, ERG is a transcription factor.
It's localized nuclear. There's a
challenge to deliver any
compound to the nuclear.
And also,
its lack of the deep well-defined pocket, like a
kinase. And this transcription factor
function as a bi-flat or large
surface,
with particular for the protein-protein interaction and the protein-DNA
interaction.
And the last, because the ERG belong to the family, which is
human members. So all these member has the ETS domain,
this has a chance to
lose the specificity.
So how to overcome the
challenge. So first, let's
come back look at the structure of this
protein.
As we know, the TMPRSS2-ERG gene fusion happen to
different breakpoint between the T2 gene and ERG genes.
But the majority of this arrangement
breakpoint happen to be
the
T2 exon 1-2 of the TMP2 gene
fused to the exon
4 of ERG, so resulting in a T2-E4 transcript.
And, so because this
is a promoter for the transcript, and upon this
translation, so it's resulting almost
full length of ERG protein, but only lack
those N-terminal 32 amino acid. So
this almost full length ERG protein include a PNT domain,
which responsible for protein-protein interaction.
It's
very well studied, including the
DNA-dependent protein kinase at AP1 complex.
And the other domain is ETS domain, which is DNA binding domain.
So therefore, in this study, we try to think about different way
to
inhibit the ERG function. So what we did, we using the
PNT domain as our target to screen the
library. We performed a domain-focused library
screening and end up with a compound we called
Pbite-1, a PNT binding inhibitor of the transcription factor
ERG1. So here the structure of the Pbite-1 and
the F03421 is a hit compound which we identify from the
library. And by SAR, we develop or
synthesize a Pbite-1, which we call lead compound, and
also we have negative compound,
747.
And then first experiment we did was,
we tried to see the binding affinity or stabilization to target
protein in vitro. So this is the DSF study, so
differential
scanning fluorimetry. And from this study, we can
see the Pbite-1 stabilize the
PNT protein in
a dose-dependent manner from
0 to 100 micromolar.
And then the next study, we try to determine the binding
affinity between this compound, Pbite-1, to the PNT domain.
We used SPR, surface plasmon resonance.
And this study give us a binding affinity of 28 micromolar.
And in order to quantify the binding affinity or the target
engagement in cell, we generate a system called a hybrid
sensor. And we
clone the hybrid tag fused to the
ERG full-length protein, and express this fused protein
in a HEK293 cell. And then we did this sensor study.
We can see here the Pbite-1 can stabilize the ERG
protein in a dose-dependent manner from
0 to 200 micromolar. The data TM is
8.7 CS.
And then finally, we did a cellular thermal shift study.
So from here we can see we have the Pbite-1, which is our positive
compound, and a negative control.
You can see even at 52 degree, this
compound can stabilize ERG protein compared to either
DMSO or negative control.
So this study
give us confidenceour compound PBIDE1 can stabilize or
engage the ERG protein either in vitro or in the cell.
So to further validate the engagement in cells, we
synthesized a biotinylated compound.
This is the structure of the biotin compound.
And then we use this biotinylated compound to pull down the endogenous
ERG protein from VCAP cells or isogenic model PC3-ERG.
So from this western blot, we can easily see the biotin PBIDE1
can nicely pull down the full-length ERG protein as
well as isogenic expressed ERG protein from PC3
ERG model.
And to further map which domain or confirm
the PNT domain is the binding allocation of the
PBIDE1, so we generate different construct or
different fragment of this protein.
And this is full-length ERG protein as well as different truncation of the protein,
and particularly this one lack of PNT domain.
So here is
the pull down study. You can see here this input, and once this
fragment
missing the PNT domain, there's no pull down, no band show up,
indicating this compound only bind to
PNT domain.
Finally, from this data, we also use the hybrid
sensor. So we generate the fused hybrid PNT
fusion protein and express in the HEK cells.
So this is the stability of the stabilization of this
curve. We can see PBIDE1 stabilize our PNT domain
protein itself.
So, the next experiment, we try to
identify the binding interface between the compound and this
protein, the
PNT domain protein. What do we have done?
We use this MR study,
best towards the MR spectra. So this is the overall
spectra. You can see among these many different
residue, amino acid residue, that's only few residue which is
shift upon binding the
PBIDE compound in a dose-dependent manner.
You can see here this titration of this compound use
different ratio of protein to the PBIDE
compound. To summarize all this data,
so we can see from this bar graph, we can see there's
three clusters very nicely
clustering into three clusters about this threshold,
.02 of the CSP, chemical
shift perturbation. So these three clusters,
so this one's located to the flexible region
of this PNT domain protein. And this cluster two and three
localize to the helix two and last
helix. So when we look at this
3D structure of the protein, because for the PNT domain protein, there's a
MR crystal structure, MR structure available.
So when we
did the map, we can see these three...
Look at this. These three clusters very nicely
form an interface, form a coherent interface,
which form
a pocket, lets the compound or the PBIDE1
to go inside and bind to this interface.
So that MR data give us very confidence.
Okay, this compound can bind to the PNT
domain surface, and this surface
formed a pocket by three clusters, which we
confirmed by MR.
So, so far we have the
biochemical, biophysical, and biochemistry data to demonstrate the
PBIDE compound can bind
to the PNT or full-length ERG protein in vitro and vivo.
But how about the phenotype? So what we did, the first
main we try to see, so what about the PBIDE affect the
cell viability in ERG positive, ERG negative cell lines.
So that's what we did in this experiment.
So we perform experiment on the cell
viability over a panel of cell lines.
The top is ERG positive, including the prostate and leukemia, and
two leukemia cell lines, and the bottom is ERG negative.
You can see the blue color is on the top and red color is on the
bottom. You can see nicely, only suppress the ERG
positive cell line.
And in line with this
cell viability study, in this apoptosis, which determined
by flow cytometry, and you can see here,
PBIDE1 can induce apoptosis only in ERG positive cell lines.
And as we know, the ERG can induce the cellular invasion.
So what we've done, we try to use PBIDE to inhibit or
block cellular invasion. So you can see here, that's a PC3-ERG model.
Upon the ERG overexpressing PC3 cell line, it's
induced the cellular invasion. But when we apply the
PBIDE1, it suppress or
block the cellular invasion. But that
inhibition doesn't do anything on the ERG negative
cell lines, which is VCAP 22RY1.
And also we know
that we have already
identifies a list of ERG regulated genes.
So here we did qPCR to see, upon the PBIDE1
treatment, a list of ERG target genes,
you can significantly repressed or down-regulated.
And we further
expand the panel of this ERG-regulated genes
by RNA-seq. So you can see here, the left heat map
is VCAP-SHERG. We can identify a list of the
ERG-regulated genes. Upon the PBIDE
treatment at different time point, you can see these genes are dramatically
suppressed.And then we further move
to the
organoid. We try to see whether these P-bite
can suppress organoid growth. So we take a PNT-established
organoid in our lab. So this is a gene model of
mouse organoid, you can see here. So this one's
ERG+ organoid, and the rest of
these different observation background.
You can see the P-bite might only suppress ERG+
organoid. And likewise, we expand the
panel of organoid to human PDX-derived organoid.
So you can see here, so these three red light is
ERG+, and these two are ERG- connected, which is driven
by CDK12 observation. So you can see here,
only the ERG+ prostate organoid are
sensitive to the P-bite treatment.
Okay, last, we
tried to do the in vivo study. Here, we did a very
preliminary in vivo study, which
intra-tumor inject the P-bite in the
xenograft model, which VCA model.
And from this, I have the immunohistochemistry study.
You can see here,
the P-bite one doesn't do anything to the ERG protein as
it's expected because the P-bite only bind to ERG protein.
But once bind or block ERG function, it
induce apoptosis, which is shown here by Tunel assay.
And this western blot further confirm the clear path of the
marker of apoptosis.
And finally we did
IH. So we try to say the
blockage of ERG function whether it can affect
the ERG-regulated genes, including MYC,
AR, HDDIB, and PLA1A, which we
already confirmed previously. So from here we can easily
see
P-bite one treatment can suppress the gene expression.
So I think this is very interesting study.
So from this study, we
established a PNT domain as a ligable domain.
We can therapeutically target ERG transcription factor.
So interestingly from
last year, the PCF scientific retreat company, Parabilis
Medicine, also presented a study.
In this study, they used the helicase degrader to
inhibit the ERG function. Later they found this
helicase also bind the PNT domain.
So therefore, this helicase bind
degrade the ERG protein. So both studies are very
interesting.
You reinforce our idea. PNT domain is really indeed
a ligable domain, which we can
employ to suppress or target
ERG-directed prostate cancer patients.
So, this is summary take home message.
So from this study, we found ERGs,
it's a truncal oncogenic driver, 50% of prostate cancer patients.
So, this
prostate-specific ERG fusion is sufficient to drive tumorigenesis.
In genetic knockdown, we showed
induce cell
death and regression. And target discovery screen
identifies small molecule which bind ERG PNT domain.
This P-bite we found is a weak but very selective.
So in term of our data showed this P-bite compound can
suppress ERG+ cell line, either a cell line or
organoid.
And, so
I think the most important this study established
ligable ERG PNT domain to represent attractive or previously
unexplored therapeutic target.
With that, so I thank you. Acknowledge
all the members, so collaborators from either
University of Michigan, from Dr. Ruichi Dai's lab, as well as
from Shanghai Institute of Chemistry, our long-term collaborator.
They provide all the compounds and
derivatives. Thank you so much, and I take any questions.
Yeah.
So I guess first question is, do you know the homology in the PNT domain
with other ETS family transcription factors?
And have you sort of explored
if there's other similar targets being engaged?
That's a very good question. So, because as I mentioned, there's
multiple members for the ETS family.
So we did research comparison. So only FLI1
has almost
identical PNT domain. The other PNT domain is not, there's no
homologous. There may be 30%,
but there's not much homology.
But,
as I mentioned, because this study is just
early stage, we still are
undergoing to assess other ETS families.
And do you understand how binding in the PNT domain is
actually inhibiting the function of ERG?
That's a very good question, too. So, actually we have done
assessment. We found once the
P-bite bind the PNT domain, it disrupt the
PPI, protein-protein interaction.
Particularly this new data, particularly ERG protein
bind to the Swiss Nef,
especially BRG1. We found once the
P-bite bind to ERG protein, disrupt the ERG and the
BRG1 interaction.
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Wang.
So our next speaker is
Dr.
Xidong Gao, who will talk about a novel
brain-penetrant BRAF inhibitor for BRAF mutant gliomas.
Okay.
Thank you, TS.
Colleagues and friends, good afternoon.
I'm from HSCode Pharmaceutical Group.
It is a real privilege to be here to demonstrate
our latest data of
HSK42360, a novel
brain-penetrant BRAF paradox breaker, which demonstrated
promising antitumor activity in patients with BRAF
mutant glioma.
Here is my disclosure information.
I will begin with its biological rationale for this
program.
As we know, BRAF V600 mutations drives
constitutive MAPK pathway activation.
While it is a well-known driver in many cancers
like melanoma, it is also important
to note that they found in gliomas
as well,
of about
3% in adult populations, and have a
higher rate of
10% and more in pediatric populations.
This provide
clearly yet challenging therapeutic opportunities.
However, the efficacy
pathway targeting has been limited
by its functional liability of the first
generation BRAF inhibitors,
that is called
paradoxical MAPK activation. When a first
generation BRAF inhibitor binds one monomer of
a RAF dimer, it can transactivate with the
drug-free partner, leading to a
reactivation of downstream pathway.
Clinically, that might cause acute intolerance,
cutaneous toxicity, and paradox driver
resistance. So the question was: How can
we overcome this?
That's where HSK42360 comes in.
Through molecular dynamics, we found that
compared to dabrafenib,
HSK42360 demonstrated
external rotation of the alpha C helix,
and thereby preventing and disrupting the
dimerization of BRAF. True consistent with
that mechanism, we observed that
HSK42360 did not induce paradox
activation in HCT116 cells,
as shown here.
And the HSK42360 also exhibits
strong in vivo potency in non-V600 mutant and
resistant models. In Class II
G469A mutant model, both
in H1755 and
1795 cells,
the IC50 value of
HSK42360 was
50,
7.6 nanomole, and 101 nanomole
respectively, compared favorably with
dabrafenib. And in the Class III
G466V mutant models, the
IC50 of HSK42360 achieved
10 nanomole.
And in the NRAS mutant resistant models,
the activity of
HSK42360 also
retained with an IC50 of
48 nanomole.
These comparators ranging from
over 100 nanomole to close to
2,000 nanomole.
Next, let me turn to brain penetration, which is
important in glioma patients. In mice, we
observed that
HSK42360 demonstrated an
unbound brain to plasma ratio,
or we can see Kp,uu of 1.1.
To put that in context, the ratio over
0.3 can be considered favorably for brain
penetration. And we can see here it
significantly outperformed the other
inhibitors, solidifying its status as a
brain-optimized compound.
The next question was: How those brain penetration can
translate into antitumor activities
in relevant models? The answer was
yes. As shown on this slide, we can see
HSK42360 significantly prolonged
survival in intracranial A375
CDX models. And as shown on the right, it
also demonstrated the tumor regression potential in glioma
PDX models.
Furthermore, HSK42360
also shows antitumor activity in vivo,
both as monotherapy or in combination with a
MEK inhibitor in models harboring Class
II and Class III
BRAFAnd furthermore, it also
shows efficacy in cetuximab plus
vemurafenib-resistant CRC PDX models,
both alone and in combination with EGFR-based
therapy.
That speaks to its broad potential.
All those preclinical data give us confidence
to move into clinic. So what can we
see in patients?
The initial
clinical data in our glioma
cohort is encouraging.
And the cutoff date, we can see
23 recurrent BRAF
V600 mutant glioma patients were enrolled
and
effectively evaluable, including 19 patients
with high-grade glioma and four patients with low-grade glioma.
And all of the patients
had undergone prior surgery, and
95.7% had received
radiotherapy. And most of the patients had received at
least one prior systematic
antitumor therapy.
Despite those pretreatment
background, we observed the ORR of patient with
high-grade glioma was 42.1%
and
50% with patient with low-grade glioma.
Among
those responders, 62.5% patient
with high-grade glioma and 50% patient
with low-grade glioma achieved more
than 80% reduction of their target lesions.
Those response is not only deep and
frequent, but also durable. For most patients,
the best response was achieved within six to
24-week window, and the clinical benefits were
maintained over time.
Here, I will show you a representative case.
This is a
28-year-old man with a recurrent WHO
Grade 3 anaplastic pleomorphic lymphoma
astrocytoma, or we can call it
APXA.
After initial surgery and
radiotherapy, the disease had recurred, leading to
a second surgery. Then after
second
recurrence, he started to receive
HSK42360.
And show on the right, we can see here in the cycle
eight, day 21, the target lesion had
completely disappeared,
representing a radiographic complete response.
Then how do those clinical data compare with
available standard of care data?
And as shown on this slide, and recognizing
the limitation of cross-study comparison,
HSK42360 demonstrated favorably
with reported dabrafenib plus trametinib
results
in recurrent BRAF V600 mutant glioma,
especially in high-grade glioma patients.
In those populations, we observed the ORR with
HSK42360 was
14.1%, compared with
33% reported for
dabrafenib plus trametinib. And the CR
rate were
15.8% versus 7%,
respectively. In addition, the median
PFS with HSK42360
was 8.2 months, compared with
3.8 months reported for dabrafenib plus
trametinib.
Although this
cross-study data should be
interpreted cautiously, the significant
difference is encouraging.
And of course,
efficacy is only one part of the whole profile.
The safety is equally important. So
as shown here,
in 69 patient,
the classic BRAF inhibitor-associated
treatment-related adverse events, or
TRAE, was remarkably reduced. For
example, pyrexia only occurred in
5.8% of patients
receiving HSK42360,
compared with 28% of patients
reporting for dabrafenib monotherapy.
And we observed no DLTs, only two
resolved CSAS, and no significant skin, ocular,
or cardiac toxicities during the study, and
no TRAEs lead to discontinuation, treatment
termination, or death.
To conclude, let me summarize the key points.First,
HSK42360 is a brain penetrant
RAF paradox breaker designed to avoid the
MAPK pathway activation. Second, by
minimizing wild type RAF-induced dimericization,
the safety profile of
HSK42360
is differentiated with reduced class
RAF inhibitor toxicities. Third, it
demonstrated
in vivo antitumor activity across class I, II,
and III of RAF mutations. Most
importantly, those preclinical antitumor
activity appear to translate into
clinical benefits in recurrent
RAF V600 mutant gliomas, especially in
high-grade gliomas.
Taken together, those data supported
HSK42360 is a promising
therapeutic strategy in recurrent
RAF mutant glioma and warrant further clinical
development. That's all for my presentations.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you.
Any questions for Dr. Gao?
Great job. I got two questions. The first is,
have you checked the efficacy in the
classical BRAF inhibitor-resistant patients in your clinical trials?
And the second question is, do you have any plan to enroll
more patients with other tumor types?
Okay, that's a good question.
First,
actually, our
research is still on early stage, and we do
enroll some
RAF resistance patients. But unfortunately,
by far, we did not
observe any patients
reach the response rate. But
we did observe
some
resistant patients
had a
tumor reduction.
So
it was considered
that
this result is partly relevant
to
the
limitation of drug exposure. So if we
can
evaluate the exposure,
we believe the response can be
found in the future.
And another question.
Yes, we
observed many types of
solid tumors like melanoma, NSCLC,
CRC, PTC, and glioma, and
cranial
rhinoglioma.
And the
responses have been observed in many
types of the
tumors,
which demonstrated the
pan-tumor activity of our
product.
Okay.
Thank you.
So next abstract will be presented by Dr.
Tan, Active RAS inhibition intercepts pancreas cancer in
mice. Thank you.
Hey. Oh, loud.
Thank you for the opportunity to present.
Today, I will be showing some preclinical work
that supports a strategy for pancreas cancer interception.
Here are my disclosures.
And as you guys may have heard, RAS is drugable.
And the molecular glues by Revolution Medicines can allow
for these inhibitors to be both multi-selective
or mutant selective. And so RMC-7977
is the preclinical analog of diraxantrasib, which is a
multi-selective RAS inhibitor. And RMC-9945
is the preclinical analog of zoldanrasib, which is a
covalent G12D selective inhibitor.
And excitingly, what we've seen is that when we deploy these molecules
in metastatic pancreas cancer in the metastatic setting,
we see that the overall response rates and disease control rates
are profound.
And that this is actually changing the landscape and really presenting a
promising therapy for patients with PDAC.
However, despite
greater than 90% of PDAC having mutations in KRAS, we know
that RAS inhibition alone is going to be insufficient to cure this disease.
And that's not surprising because we know that tumor heterogeneity and
cellular plasticity are persistent issues when
we deal with single agent interventions.
And when we think about it, when we think about a normal cell becoming invasive
disease,
we know that its genetic diversity amplifies.
And yet despite that, at the point of peak genetic
diversity, AKA metastatic disease, is where we're
grossly deploying RAS inhibition.
However, we know that cancer is a Darwinian process, and so with all this
variation, it shouldn't be a surprise to know that there's going to be a cell
that survives a therapeutic insult.And so
unfortunately, this is always going to be an obstacle with our current paradigms
of cancer treatment.
And so I present to you an idea, cancer interception, which
tries to intervene earlier in those steps of tumorigenesis.
And with cancer interception, the thought is that we can intervene on these
precursor cells to impair their ability to become
cancer.
And ultimately, this can avoid all the heterogeneity and
the plasticity that may be seen in later stages of the disease.
And so when we look at this through the lens of pancreas cancer, we know that these
pre-early lesions,
we know that the acinar cells can undergo reversible metaplasia,
resulting in early lesions known as ADMs.
This process is typically reversible unless an acquisition of KRAS
occurs within these cells.
At this point, this becomes irreversible and panin lesions then result
within the pancreas. And then subsequent loss of tumor suppressor cells then
accelerates the path down tumorigenesis, and they become
invasive disease. And over the past couple of years, there's been a lot of
interesting research regarding panin.
First, we know that panin
are present in the majority of healthy people.
We also know that individuals can harbor hundreds of independent panin lesions,
and KRAS is ubiquitous within these lesions.
And so given this paradigm,
it's an interesting question, if these precursor lesions have RAS
mutations,
how long do we need to wait before we intervene on them?
And so we asked, do panin respond to RAS inhibition?
And in order to do this, we assessed this in the KPC mouse, which harbor both KRAS
G12D as well as a P53 mutation within the pancreas of
these mice.
On average, these mice develop panin by one to two months of age, develop
tumors by three to four months of age, and then they usually expire by five
months of age.
And so for this first experiment, we took nine-week-old KPC mice, which harbor
known panin lesions, and then exposed them to 10 days of
RAS inhibition. And then we evaluated them at endpoint using a
technique known as CODA.
For those of you guys that don't know, CODA is a technique that uses machine
learning to analyze serial sections of H&Es,
and this allows for the 3D reconstruction of tissues.
In this case, when we apply it to the mouse pancreas, we can actually evaluate the
entirety of the mouse pancreas.
And then when we use CODA to identify
histologic lesions of interest, we can actually look
through the entire pancreas for these microscopic precursor lesions across our
experimental conditions.
And in this setting, when we reconstruct the pancreata under
these various conditions, we can see that RAS inhibition is eliminating these
precursor cells. Interestingly, even at this stage of the disease, if you
count the number of panin, it's about 400 at this
time point, and this significantly decreases as you expose these mice to RAS
inhibition.
We then asked the question of what is happening within these cells?
Why are they going away?
And so we assessed this by IHC, and even after three doses of
each of the RAS inhibitors, what we found is an elevation of cleaved caspase-3,
suggesting that these pre-malignant cells are undergoing cell death.
However, in addition to cell death, we also asked the question of whether or not
transdifferentiation was also contributing to the disappearance of these panin
lesions histologically. And we didn't find any evidence for this,
and this mirrors and is
consistent with the evidence from the inducible KRAS models that was published
almost over a decade ago.
And so we see that these precursor lesions are disappearing.
We then asked,
does this alter the natural history of PDAC?
And so we again took KPC mice, made sure that they did not have
tumors, exposed them to four weeks of RAS inhibition,
took them off therapy,
and then continued to monitor them for tumor development.
And so in mice, we can actually use high-resolution ultrasound to
diagnose tumors. This method is highly sensitive.
We're able to detect tumors as small as five to 10 cubic millimeters.
And what we found is that even four weeks of RAS inhibition alone is able
to significantly delay the onset of tumors within these mice.
And that delay in tumor onset also translates to
an overall survival benefit within these mice.
And so we have shown previously that T cells are an important part
of maintaining tumor control and RAS inhibition within
preclinical models of mice. So we asked the question of whether or not T cells were
also contributing
to this effect.
And so we repeated the same experiment, but during this iteration, we actually
depleted CD4 and CD8 T cells, both during RAS inhibition
and subsequently thereafter,
and then monitored again for tumor development.
Here I'm showing you the results from the prior experiment in the dotted
lines. And what we found is that when we deplete T cells, it actually
did not really influence the time to tumor onset,
nor the survival of these mice. And so from this, we concluded that
the T cells were not playing a role in the RAS inhibition interception
phenotype that we were
seeing.
And so we know that a defined amount of RAS inhibition
provides overall survival benefit.
We then hypothesized that if we go back in and intervene on panin again, that
this would provide
a more extended benefit. To perform this experiment, we again
took seven-week-old mice and exposed them to a week of RAS inhibition
every other week. So a week on of therapy and a week off of therapy, and monitored
them again for tumor development.And what we found was that
the strategy was highly effective in delaying the time to
tumor onset within these mice, delaying it by over 200 days.
And this raises an interesting question of whether or not
it makes sense to intervene earlier within this disease.
And so in order to assess this experimentally, what we did was we looked at the
survival of mice under this interception arm and compared
it to the survival of mice that received RAS inhibition after a
tumor had formerly developed, what I'm calling the treatment arm.
And what we found is that even we know that
RAS inhibition after a tumor develops provides benefit,
and in this experiment, we see that mice prolong their
survival by two months when you treat their tumors.
However, as you start and you eliminate pannens,
preventing tumors from forming,
you can actually extend overall survival by over a year in KPC mice.
This provides really strong evidence for interception within this
model over treatment.
And so we then asked the question of whether or not this is a class effect.
Can we use other RAS inhibitors to mimic the same effect?
And so again, we took KPC mice and exposed them to 10 days
of MRTX1133, which is a G12D
specific inhibitor.
And we actually found really profound sterilization of these
pannen lesions that was also confirmed in our 3D
reconstructions.
And then again asked the same question of whether or not we can
provide metronomic
dosing to eliminate pannens recurrently.
So similar to the prior experiment,
a week at a time, we gave RAS inhibition.
In this case, we gave it every three weeks instead of every other week
and found something quite similar.
And so I just want to comment that this experiment went on for so long that we had
to re-genotype a lot of these mice to make sure that they still had the RAS
allele. And the other thing that I'll point out is that the
oldest mouse in the study lived to about 600 days, which is
close to the lifespan of a KRAS
wild-type mouse.
And I think this is a testament to the
power and potential of cancer interception over treatment.
And so the key takeaways,
RAS inhibition can eliminate pannen.
If you eliminate pannen, you can delay tumor onset and prolong overall survival.
And if you intercept before you treat,
it may be easier to impede on
pre-cancer rather than trying to catch up to it later.
And so with that, I'd like to thank everyone
who's helped, Ben Stanger and Bob Vonderheide, as well as my funding
sources. And then I'm going to put in a pitch that I'm starting a lab in the
fall, so if you're interested in studying interception, send me an email.
I'm looking to hire and I'm looking for collaborators. Thanks.
Questions?
Over there.
Hi.
Great talk.
Also, the paper in "Science" is beautiful. Congratulations.
Thank you.
It's really hard in the clinics to catch early stage PDAC,
so let alone pannens. How do you see this coming
into translating into actual benefit of potentially targeting those pannens?
That's a great question. I think the patients that we need to look at are the
patients who are of highest risk for
developing pancreas cancer. And so when we look
across different studies, those patients could include those who
have high risk pancreatic cysts,
patients who
have germline predisposition syndromes, and then patients who also have clinical
features such as new onset diabetes or chronic
pancreatitis.
There's obviously a lot more that we need to study in this, but I think that's a
good starting point
to trying to figure out who's going to benefit from this type of study.
Thanks.
Wonderful job.
I'm wondering, when you are doing the
immune cell depletion during the drug treatment,
have you ever tried depletion of
other cell types, such as macrophages or fibroblasts, as we know that
pancreatic cancer is heavily related to these
fibroblasts? Yeah.
We have not done that experiment yet.
But what we do see is that we do see a decrease in macrophages with RAS
inhibition, and so I think that could potentially potentiate the effect,
but-
Okay. Thank you
... we haven't done that yet.
Because he took my question, I'm going to ask a different question.
I'm wondering whether you think,
to the room,
Niranjan was mentioning maybe we can do this KRAS
cleansing. And
based on what we know about KRAS mutations in pannen,
all of us are probably walking around with them.
So do you think that in the future, this could be even a
prevention for a general population?
Depends how far in the future do you want me to think?
But I think-
Be a dreamer.
Yeah. So I think
if we
look at what we're doing for primary prevention of cardiac disease,
right?Some people think statin should be in the
water.
I think the most important thing is actually safety of these drugs and tolerability
of these drugs. And so I think if we find a safe,
tolerable drug, then I think we can be dreamers.
Can I ask one question to follow up on that?
Because it's very hard to cure mice that are constantly getting new penance, and
your survival is amazing what you're getting there.
Do you think of developing a system where you're just getting a one-time incidence
of Cre recombination and see if you can just, and the question I've just asked,
come in one time, treat, and then never get cancer in those mice?
Yeah, I'm working on it.
All right, thank you.
So our last speaker is Dr. Wolpin,
and he'll be talking about
a clinical trial of nab-paclitaxel and
gemcitabine chemotherapy with deruxnaratib in the first line setting.
Excellent. Well, on behalf of my co-authors who you can see here,
just to thank the session organizers for the invitation to speak today.
So we're going to talk about today initial results from a clinical
trial evaluating deruxnaratib plus
chemotherapy in the first-line treatment of patients with
metastatic pancreatic cancer.
These are my disclosures.
So I think as this audience knows, and Haemin was just talking about,
pancreatic cancer is a very difficult disease.
So it often does present late, and we don't have nearly as
many treatment options as we would like.
And so currently in the first-line setting, for most patients with metastatic
pancreatic cancer, we use multi-agent chemotherapy.
And there are two basic programs we tend to use, either a gemcitabine-based
program or a 5-FU-based program. For the gemcitabine-based
programs, that's usually gemcitabine plus nab-paclitaxel.
And for the 5-FU-based programs, that's generally FOLFIRINOX or
NALIRIFOX. The efficacy data in that
setting has been historically, if you look across a number of different clinical
trials, a response rate in about the 30% to 40% range
for objective response rate, a median PFS in the five to
seven-month range, and median OS in the nine to 12-month
range. So this really does leave a lot to be desired, much
improvements that we can try to identify.
And it turns out, as was just discussed, that over 90% of
pancreas cancers carry an activating oncogenic mutation in RAS.
And so this really provides us an opportunity to target this as
a novel therapeutic approach for patients with metastatic pancreatic cancer.
So the drug we'll talk about today is deruxnaratib.
It's an oral potent RAS on multi-selective
non-covalent inhibitor. It targets GTP, so
active on state RAS at codons 12,
13, and 61, as well as wild-type RAS.
And it enters the cell, binds to cyclophilin A to form a binary
complex, which then binds to GTP-bound RAS
and sterically hinders the ability of effector proteins to bind to
GTP-bound RAS, and then suppresses downstream
signaling. So the reason for this trial, which is a first-line
clinical trial, was data that was coming from patients who had been previously
treated. So a previous clinical trial, Phase I, II study, had
demonstrated that in second line and beyond, deruxnaratib had a
manageable safety profile and substantial clinical
activity. And that prompted the current study.
So the study that we'll talk about is called the GI102
platform study. This is actually a larger study that involves
RAS on inhibitors in different combinations across GI
cancers. We're going to talk today about sub-protocol C,
which is a protocol specifically for patients with metastatic
pancreatic cancer that has not been previously treated.
So this is a first line study, and it combines deruxnaratib
plus gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel.
You can see to the left the eligibility criteria.
I think really the key here again is that this is a first-line study, so patients
were not allowed to have received systemic therapy previously for
their metastatic disease. There were two dose escalation cohorts, dose
level 1A and 1B. Both of these cohorts involved
deruxnaratib at 200 milligrams orally once daily.
In dose level 1A, gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel was given in its
standard form, so days one, eight, and 15 on a 28-day
cycle. And in 1B, it was given on day one and day 15,
dropping day eight, again on a 28-day cycle.
After review of data from initial patients enrolled to the two dose
levels, dose level 1B was chosen as the dose expansion.
You can see the objectives were safety tolerability as the primary objective.
Secondary objectives were anti-tumor activity and exploratory
objectives around molecular response using ctDNA.
The data we'll present is from dose level 1B from the dose
escalation backfill dose expansion, so 40
patients total that we'll talk about.
So these are the demographics and the baseline characteristics for these 40
patients. You can see the median age is around 70 years, very common for
pancreatic cancer. About half and half men and women, and
ECOG performance zero and one. 70% of patients had liver
metastases, again, very common in this setting.
And some patients had had prior surgery, but all patients had metastatic disease
at the time of enrollment to the study.
And then you can see to the right the RAS genotypes.
So 50% of patients had G12D mutations in KRAS,
25% had G12V, 18% G12R, three
patients had other mutant alleles.
This again is very common, a very common distribution for what we see in
terms of RAS mutant alleles in pancreatic
cancer.So to start with the safety.
So this is safety tolerability of duraxonrasib plus gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel. These are the treatment-related adverse events by
CTCAE grading. You can see to the left, in the left column is any
grade, and to the right is grade three or greater
adverse events. You can see in the any grade column, the most
common adverse event was rash, which we have seen before with
duraxonrasib, with the vast majority of patients getting some rash.
For most patients, this was low-grade rash.
Again, usually now we've seen across studies about 10% to 15%
of patients get a grade three or higher rash, and it was similar in this study.
If you focus on the grade three or greater column, the toxicities that you
see are essentially the toxicities that we know when you look at
duraxonrasib individually, when you look at chemotherapy individually.
There were not new safety signals, but you could see, again, adverse events as you
would expect from both of these drugs, or really three drugs,
because two chemotherapy agents at the same time.
So if we then look at what led to dose modifications and how many dose
modifications there were among the 40 patients, I'll highlight a few of these
numbers. If you look at dose reduction, you can see
35% of patients needed a dose reduction in duraxonrasib,
and 58% of patients needed a dose reduction in gem
nab-paclitaxel. If you look at dose discontinuation, about
5% of patients discontinued duraxonrasib because of
toxicity, and 15% of chemotherapy.
Again, chemotherapy does carry with it significant side effects.
We do see discontinuations of chemotherapy in normal practice.
And you can see the mean and the median dose intensity for the duraxonrasib
and for the chemotherapy was between 80% and 90%.
If we then look at the efficacy for duraxonrasib plus gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel, you see to the left the waterfall plot with a sizable
number of patients having substantial reductions in tumor burden.
If you look in the table on the right, the objective response rate was
58%. This is the confirmed ORR. And you can see the
disease control rate was 90%.
If you look at landmark times for PFS and OS at
six months, you see 84% of patients had
a landmark six-month PFS and 90% of patients six-month
landmark OS. We were unable to calculate median PFS and
OS because there were not enough events yet to calculate a stable estimate for the
medians.
If we then look at the ctDNA as a marker of molecular response,
we had 28 patients where this was possible of the 40.
These 28 patients required a pre-treatment blood sample with a
measurable RAS allele, a K RAS allele that we could measure.
And then they needed to have a second blood sample collected either cycle two, day
one or cycle three, day one, where we also could measure
ctDNA. What you could see on the left is the
reduction in ctDNA or ctDNA RAS variant
allele fraction between the pre and the on-treatment samples.
And then if you look to the right, what you can see is 96% of patients at
a 50% or greater decrease in ctDNA RAS
variant allele fraction, and 61% had complete
clearance of ctDNA where the RAS mutation was no longer
identifiable in the blood.
So if we ask what are the summaries and conclusions?
So the summaries and conclusions from this initial study of 40 patients
receiving duraxonrasib and gemcitabine nab-paclitaxel
as first-line treatment showed a manageable safety profile with
consistent toxicities of what we know from the drugs from prior
studies at a mean and median dose intensity between 80% and
90% across patients and across the study.
The combination demonstrated compelling initial evidence of activity
with an objective response rate of 58% and a disease
control rate of 90%. In addition, there was some early evidence
of durability of this response with a six-month landmark
PFS of 84% and an OS of 90%.
Again, as reference, a landmark of PFS in chemotherapy in the
first line setting is about 50% from larger trials.
Early on-treatment clearance of ctDNA was seen in almost two-thirds of
patients. And these data, along
with other pieces of data, have now led to
an opening and an initial enrollment of the Resolute 303 trial, which
is a phase three clinical trial, and the next slide will show the
schema of that. I would also point you to and draw your attention to an
abstract that's being presented now actually at the poster session by Dr.
Eileen O'Reilly. This abstract is looking again at a first-line setting
for patients with metastatic pancreatic cancer, and that abstract looking at
duraxonrasib alone, not with chemotherapy.
So this is the design of the study that's now open and enrolling the Resolute
303 study. Again, if you look to the left for the eligibility, these are patients
with metastatic pancreatic cancer.
No prior treatment for their metastatic disease is allowed.
And these patients are randomized to one of three different arms, either
duraxonrasib alone, duraxonrasib plus gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel, or as the standard arm gemcitabine and
nab-paclitaxel. And you can see a joint primary endpoint of
PFS and OS.
So I'd just like to acknowledge the many patients who contributed to these
data, the families who supported them through their treatment, the
clinical investigators, and the staff who helped take care of them, the Revolution
Medicines team, and then all of you for your attention. So thank you very much.
Thank you, Brian. Any questions for Brian from the audience?
Hi.
Two questions if I may, but I'll go in order.
First, any plan to allow crossover in the RAS 303?So
crossover is not built into that study.
I think as has been seen, though, data from the second-line study,
RASloot 302, has been released and will be presented
at ASCO in about six weeks. So there may be opportunities to receive
that drug depending upon what happens from that.
But it's not built into that study, no.
All right. Also, I note that you went with a 200 milligram dose here, whereas it's
300 as monotherapy. Is that just a tolerability issue,
or?
Yeah, I think it was as we were evaluating the different dose cohorts, really
trying to maintain dose intensity the best that we could to really try to
retain sustained MAP kinase pathway inhibition from the
patients that were enrolled, it seemed that the 200 milligram dose would allow us
to do that better, and that's what was taken forward.
Thank you. Great.
Thanks for those questions.
Go ahead,
sir. Yep.
Well, from Lemgo, Munich University, Germany. Great talk, Brian.
I have a little bit of a concern regarding the
safety. This appears to me a very toxic combination,
and my patients, at least, are frail and might be not
suitable for this trial. Honestly, I would be somewhat
reluctant to enroll patients in a Phase III trial.
What are your plans to mitigate toxicity in the ongoing
303?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. So thank you for that question.
I think you can divide these into two different things.
There's the toxicity that comes from chemotherapy, of which we definitely
saw. I think we are all used to managing that toxicity,
and that needs to be done in the 303 study as we would do in our standard care.
I think for the toxicities that are specific to deruxinribase, I
think there are really two that do require some proactive management.
One is the rash, and the other is mucositis.
And so what got instituted along the way, not all the patients
had this, but we've learned as we've gone, is prophylaxis for the rash,
similar to how we handle EGFR toxicity.
And that's now something that when I treat my patients with deruxinribase, I use
that in these trials, which is prophylaxis.
And there are also opportunities to do the same for the mucositis.
And so I think if you use the prophylaxis, what you see is that the
intensity of these side effects are less, and we also are learning with our
dermatology colleagues again, how to manage the rash, and I think there are some
newer ways we're using topical approaches to do that.
So are there toxicities? Yes, as you would expect from the individual
components, but I think those can be managed using approaches that we
have developed.
But your Grade 3 plus tox was
73% in this trial. Can you
justify treating older patients and less fit patients?
So I think you, as always, would need to make decisions on an
individual patient-by-patient basis.
But again, I would say having treated patients on the study, I found that these
things were manageable as long as we were proactive about the rash and the
mucositis, and again, used our usual approaches to manage the
chemotherapy toxicity.
All right. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Over here to the left.
Hi. Jesse Yu, San Francisco. So question,
did you see any ethnicity difference in terms of response and the rash in the
trial? Because I don't see the ethnicity background information
in the presentation. And the second one is, if you compare this
to the monotherapy poster, do you feel like
the chemo combo benefits risk profile is more appealing,
or it's hard to tell?
Mm-hmm. Yeah, let me take the second one.
So I would say across the single agent and the chemotherapy,
in both, I would say the activity looks promising.
I would say we should be careful when we
compare a small study, because they're each still small studies, to
larger studies where we've treated now thousands and many thousands of patients
with chemotherapy. But I would say the initial efficacy data does look
promising for either as a single agent deruxinribase or with
chemotherapy. I think we need to learn what is appropriate.
Is it appropriate to give it alone, and how much chemotherapy we'll add?
There's actually substantial preclinical data suggesting adding chemotherapy to
RAS inhibition can be more effective, but we
don't know that in people. So I think really the goal of the 303 trial
is to answer your question. Is how much more benefit do you get
from chemotherapy? And we know chemotherapy causes side effects.
When I've given talks like this in the past, I've always said, "I'd rather not give
any chemotherapy at all." If there's ways that we can attack this
tumor without using more toxic or treatments that have more
side effects, we would much prefer.
I think the trial will help us figure out really what's the best approach.
And then tell me again, you asked if the rash was related to efficacy.
Was that the first part?
No, the first question is about is there any ethnicity
sensitivity, like
say, Asian patient, do they respond similarly or no?
Oh, I see.
Different.
Oh, that's an interesting question.
So I think that question for deruxinribase will be better
answered from the 302 trial. These are small studies and
not, I think, enough numbers to really understand what you're
asking, but it's an important question you're asking, and I think the 302
trial, which is the second line randomized trial, which enrolled people
all over the world, will give us a better ability to answer your question, which is
a good one.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah.
Irving Tiriac, UCSD. Wonderful work, Brian.
Congratulations to you and the team of clinicians behind these trials.
What can you tell us anecdotally about the patients that progress on therapy?
How do they do on the second line chemotherapy or whatever else you're going to
put them on on second line?
Mm-hmm. And are you thinking about specific things like efficacy or toxicity,
or what sort of are you thinking about?
Therapy after they fail RAS inhibition.
Okay. So I'm not sure I have a full
picture to really tell you. I think
we certainly now have been treating quite a number of patients with chemotherapy
post RAS inhibition, whether it's on this study or
others.I can't say it's really stuck out to me that there's much
difference there. Again, not to go back again to the 302 trial, but
I think that will be a useful place, too, where we are in patients on that trial
who got randomized to RAS inhibition, many of them do go on to get
chemotherapy after that. So it may allow us to think a little bit more
about
efficacy post-RAS inhibition, but I don't really have any
aggregated data at this point to answer that well.
Well, it's good to hear that we're not creating some sort of
crazy monster disease every time.
No, I don't think so. Yeah.
All right, we'll go over here to the left. Sir?
Hi, Ben Zeskin from ImmuniRing. Thanks, Brian, for an excellent talk.
I was curious if you could speak at all about the patient's ability to
maintain weight, cachexia, and whether the stomatitis or
any of the GI symptoms affect their ability to maintain
weight.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, sure. So I don't think I
have
specific data off the top of my head that I could quote you about weight, per se.
What I would say is very much in this disease, your ability to
maintain weight is highly correlated with your ability to maintain tumor
control. And if you control the tumor, patients do
substantially better with maintaining their weight.
Obviously, again, we do have to manage what side effects come up, including
mucositis, if that were to occur. But what I would say is that for
many of these patients, the longer you control the disease, the more
they maintain their weight and the better they're able to
keep up their oral intake, and it's when the disease starts to progress
that that becomes more problematic.
And we've seen that not just in RAS inhibitor trials.
That's a phenomenon we've seen in pancreatic cancer across many trials, including
trials of different chemotherapy programs.
So I would say control the tumor, and you generally
control some of the weight loss that these patients experience.
Thank you.
Yeah. Yeah, thanks.
Hello. Congratulations. I'm Angela Lamarca from Madrid, Spain.
I have two questions.
Yeah.
First one is about the chemotherapy and the combination of both.
Taking into account the time to response, do you think maybe a period of
induction chemotherapy plus the KRAS inhibition and then maintenance KRAS
inhibition could be something we could consider?
Mm-hmm.
The second question is more on the strategy we are now having the
G12D inhibitors in the first line setting as well being developed.
How do you see the field moving forward?
And congratulations, because we never saw this waterfall plot for our patients
before, so that's fantastic.
Thank you. Those are great questions.
I always struggle with two questions in a row because I have to remember them both.
All right, so for the first one, the maintenance
idea. So if you see the design of RASlue
303, in some ways it incorporates what you're describing, right?
Which is the idea is that you use a period of chemotherapy
to really push back the tumor substantially to the maximum that you
are able, and then remove the chemotherapy for tolerability,
but maintain the response you have obtained by using direct and Rasib
after that, right? So the 303 design is for six months to do
that. I also agree, I think, again, I would
like someday to not have to give chemotherapy, but if we think that that's
really going to be for a shorter period of time necessary to get the
maximal response, that may be worthwhile, and those
ideas were incorporated in that design.
So I think that's a wonderful idea.
I would say in terms of the mutant allele-specific versus
multi-selective inhibitors, I think that will have to play out.
It is such an amazing time, right? In some ways
almost unprecedented time, where we have so many different inhibitors to
the same target, to KRAS, but they all work somewhat
differently. They have different mechanisms. They have different specificities.
Some are IV, some are oral. I think this is something we will have to
see play out in the clinic, knowing that not every allele-specific
inhibitor is the same as every other allele-specific inhibitor either.
I think it's going to take the body of evidence to tell.
We could talk for a lot longer, and in some of the sessions here at ACR, this has
been discussed in more depth, why there are some pros and some
cons to each of those approaches, whether it's mutant allele-specific or
multi-selective, and happy to stay behind and talk some
more. But I think at the end of the day, we are in an unprecedented
time in pancreas cancer, and we are going to see this play out in
real time in the clinic, and I think we'll be able to pick what we think are the
winners and help our patients the most.
All right. Thank you, Dr. Wolpin. Thanks everyone for coming.